I'm breaking news out of the US now and  the Ukrainian President Vladimir  zielinski we saw him in bakmut earlier  is expected to visit Washington tomorrow  dependent on security details that is  according to the Associated Press News  Agency U.S media reporting that Mr  zielinski will possibly visit the White  House and meet the U.S President Joe  Biden well that comes after Nancy Pelosi  sent this a statement to members of  Congress saying I'm following up on the  leader's notice of the schedule by  encouraging all members to be physically  present at our session on Wednesday  night we are ending a very special  session of the 117th congress with  legislation that makes progress for the  American people as well as support for  our democracy please be present for a  very special focus on Democracy on  Wednesday night we await official  confirmation from Mr zielinski's office